Ryann Rainbow six siege got some DLC
yesterday operation dusty snorts or des
line or some some dust variant of it we
got two new operators we got a new map
the question I want to ask today is are
these free DLC updates good for Rainbow
six siege the new operators Blackbeard
and valve what do you think about their
performance so far so far I liked them
both you know we've talked about how the
headshot game has become so significant
to the more twitch side of Rainbow six
siege gameplay and Blackbeard is sort of
like a bit of an antidote to that you
know he has the gun shield ability that
he can put basically as a like a
ballistic shield he can put on top of
his gun it gives him I don't what you
see like head cover he definitely
doesn't give him body cover like the
regular rail it basically gives him some
protection from head shots and that's
pretty good because you know as we've
talked about the helmets on these
characters are purely cosmetic and a lot
of Rainbow six siege right now is the
head shot game it seems like people have
just got that dialed in and often time
gun fights are over before you even know
you're in a gunfight maybe the gun
shield sort of extends those gunfights a
little bit and makes him a little bit
more of an aggressive character who can
take slight slightly bigger chances you
can take bigger chances especially when
peeking into a room or in through a
window or an entrance like you don't
have to worry nearly as much about just
peeking through a window and then
getting a kill screen the other
character is Valkyrie so she's a
defender who has cameras the interesting
thing about her is that I feel like
she's a really good team player and
she's good for situational awareness
like I've had times we broke out a
window and spotted an entire team coming
in but if you're not playing with a good
team that can utilize that information
when you communicate it to them I just
don't see her as being as good as Frost
who when you see frost on the map you
have to be careful because you actually
have to go slower and that changes the
way an entire round is played so what do
you think about maybe val versus
previous DLC character Frost
I actually prefer Val to frost at this
point in the game
at probably four out of five times I'm
not catching anybody with a welcome mat
I might get one and I know one is enough
but most of the time I'm not getting
there and with Valkyrie I'm getting
cameras additional cameras up you spot
somebody they know they've been spotted
and now they got to go looking for that
it's a good distraction the cameras
themselves are better cameras there's
they have a 360 degree rotation
unlike the mounted ones very wide angle
lens in there in full color the actual
danger that I ran into the most is that
I had a little bit of a kind of camera
addiction where you know Valkyrie comes
with four cameras and when you first get
your hands on her you're thinking about
where can you put those cameras and four
is kind of actually a lot if you're not
used to it and once you get all four of
them up and the round starts you're
getting in there seeing how your
placement was and if you have a good
angle on things and you might be dead by
the time you're done doing that
Victoria so the new map that they've
added is called border it's kind of a
very destructible medium-sized compound
it's in a Middle Eastern setting I don't
want to talk so much about the map
itself because I think it'll be well
covered I would like to talk about how I
think that the the rate that these maps
are being released because of good
intentions is not really working for
Rainbow six siege they're releasing
about one map every four months and
they're releasing it free to the whole
community which is a great idea because
then you don't divide your player base
up especially later in a games lifecycle
but it's interesting because in addition
to adding this map free they also kind
of sold people who are passionate about
this game a season pass and for them
they sort of paid for DLC and now
they're getting very minimal DLC and
they're also being kicked into this kind
of insane I think kind of out of control
micro transaction system yeah I get the
impression that Ubisoft wasn't
comfortable with the idea of an
aggressive like DLC model and they
wanted to do something that was very
light and maybe not expecting it to be a
very large community wanted to run with
the three model and when they budgeted
it out it paired down to one map per DLC
I would I wouldn't expect more than the
two operators I think that that seems
appropriate like two operators per DLC
seems fine to me but I think something
like three maps is standard but one map
doesn't seem right at all and especially
when you consider that that map is there
aren't playlists that you know that we
get into you it's not like other games
where there's either randomization or a
mode type that you opt into you just
play casual or ranked multiplayer and
what we're seeing in a weird kind of
irony is the downside of having such a
robust to map play list out of the gate
and the vanilla version which we saw
with black ice and now we're seeing here
which is you have to lock into playing
the new map and
you may or may not see it in a week you
know even if you have even if you're a
season pass holder and to me the one
clear perk being that you get the
operators for a week without anybody
else you might not play the new map I
think that happened to you last time on
black ice where I had been on I had been
on a yacht a couple of times and you
still hadn't seen it so overall do you
think this free DLC model is working for
Rainbow six siege I do not like it I
don't see the clear benefit to season
pass holders having operators a week
early is nice but that's about it in
terms of all of these extra things that
they're throwing out there to purchase
like the charms and the face masks I
kind of liked in the skins too I the
weapon skins I like those things a bit
but for season pass holders there you
would think they would comp a little bit
more of that and say hey you guys get
your a couple more items as a season
pass holder because those charms as
ridiculous as they look are also 30,000
renown apiece that's for a dedicated
player that's AG like a week at least
30,000 you get like 300 a match so the
what's the value proposition there and
the benefit for season pass holder I
don't see it for the community at large
I don't think it's enough is one map
enough to bring back somebody who walked
away and for how long and a game where
in its best moments is tactical also
kind of requires practice and if I've
been gone for two months and I come back
to hopefully play one map and fight to
get one new operator and and if I don't
have the season pass I have to pay the
renowned to get the operator and then a
renowned on top of that to get the
attachments for their weapons I think
it's just way too uphill it's it's not
accessible enough it's nice that it's
free and it's nice that it's available
to everybody but the barrier of entry is
still somehow high in an unfortunate way
all right well thank you for joining us
in our conversation of the new Rainbow
six siege
line out now for everybody for more
coverage of Rainbow six siege stay tuned
the game spot calm
you